all right we're going to keep it not as
windy that's the good thing about our
memorial day monday we've got a few high
clouds out there and they're showing up
so i had a question in my mind when
bianca was talking about the flag and
she interviewed bobby oates talking
about putting the black ribbon if you
can't fly your flag at half staff you
can drape a black ribbon over your flag
to show respect for uh those who have
fallen during military awards and
service uh on your flag and so that's
one way to do it there is just get a
long black ribbon and put it at the top
of your flagpole if you've got your flag
out and you can't adjust it for half sta
half staff 65 degrees right now east
northeast breezes at 14 miles an hour
sunrise at 5 26 sunset at 7 51. we're a
little cooler than we were yesterday at
this hour and the air is still still dry
outside the valley it's been quite windy
along the river north wind still up
around 30 miles an hour for laughlin 75
degrees there a few breezes in trump at
61 54 at indian springs 64 and some
breezes in boulder city this morning 61
in mesquite 42 in caliani and 25 up the
road in ely so we'll look for temps
up to maybe 60 degrees up there at mount
charleston cooler of course at lee
canyon and winds through the mountains
and also breezy out at the lake
they had to close willow creek early
yesterday because they were at capacity
expected to be crowded again today
please take the life jackets so we've
got a front right over us look at all
the rain and snow up north we'll take
every bit of it that we can get
until the hot summer months arrive 84
degrees
for us this afternoon 84 94 is normal
back to 89 tomorrow slow warm-up this
week 93
wednesday and 100 back on thursday
breezy and slightly cooler with some
clouds around on saturday